they'll take their swings off the
veteran right-hander matt harvey 32
years old and boy what a swing it's been
from first half to second half for him
two down with nikki lopez at second base
[Applause]
and a game saving catch in the night
there's a line drive to center field
it's gonna drop in front of the center
fielder mckenna here comes lopez around
to score and the royals take the early
one-nothing lead
so a clutch two-out base hit by andrew
benintendi
[Applause]
blocked by severino he'll throw it
through to second back to first ben
intend he is dead meat
ben attended just got hung up in between
start number 28 and he's given the
royals over 152 innings this year
the 2-1 is hit on the ground left side
fielded by lopez quick toss got him nice
play by nicky one two three go the
orioles we head to the second
oh miner
good effort and they still get
mateo
mike miners sets down the first six
rv 1-1
it's slow pitcher runner takes off the
throw up the line it's not in time
i think that the orioles one another
look at this to see if maybe you're not
olivares came off the second base back
trying to figure out if he came off
as he bring he slid in with his front
foot first that popped up and over he
tried to hold his back shin
which was flat along the base
and hold it on that way
they're gonna argue he's out
wit lines one to left field and that
will be off the bottom of the wall so
that
caught stealing is huge
which double comes with nobody on base
[Applause]
and there goes whit two third and that
throw is going to end up in left field
hayes has a short throw to the plate but
that's high
so hayes was heads up and left he was
charging before
the throw even got away so that had a
chance to be close but
whit
forces an air with a steal of third and
he comes home
on the air too baltimore has two on with
one out with the top of the order coming
up
jones and gutierrez the runners
and they'll be off on a ground ball to
santana and he hit gutierrez in the back
might have hit him in the helmet
[Applause]
everybody is safe
there's a little something brewing here
bases loaded
salvi sets up down and away and the
pitch is there and mount castle strikes
out on a changeup
got him
mike miner
[Music]
does not allow a big inning in the third
tonight working around the base is
loaded with one out great pitching and
the royals have runners at first and
third with one out
nikki lopez deep to right field and
off the wall
scores
whit goes to third
and nikki lopez has an rbi double
and the royals lead three nothing in the
fifth oh for a second
i thought he got his second homer
and he'll get ben and tendy with the
bases loaded and one out
then attendee pulls it on the ground
right side the play is to the plate and
the throw is wide
so mount castle at first figured there
was one out
and tried to
cut down wit at home plate but he pulled
the throw
and the royals take a four nothing lead
in the fifth inning it's two away to
monday who will bat right-handed for the
first time
and got him swinging
there's the breaking ball for a bond to
lead the bases loaded there is
major league second leading home run
hitter
trying to chase down shohei ohtani he
said 43. perez is at 41.
oh salvi that sounded good deep center
field back goes mckenna and it is gone
for number 42.
i don't know what spot
[Music]
he hasn't hit it too over the wall i
mean he has fanned out his home runs
from foul pole to foul pole and that one
was dead center it was loud that's for
sure salvador perez hits it another one
and now salvia is all by himself third
all-time in royals history
14 years in pro bowl 11 years in the
minors including a tour over in mexico
and yes
he will make his major league debut for
the orioles
right now
going to start his big league career
with a flying ball to center from
monteci
and a catch from ryan mckenna three
pitches all strikes a fly out and
welcome to the show manny
attended high school in arizona
our herd out to left field this is going
to hang in there for hayes
two flyouts
to start manny barretta's big league
career and he strikes out taylor looking
you get a little more on the inside
corner when you've been in the minors
for 11 seasons
how about you manny beretta
first and third and nobody out here in
the bottom of the eighth
the history can peril for austin 14-game
hit streak coming into tonight
first pitch attack for hayes that one
hit well to right center field that one
is off the base of the wall
hit streak to 15 hayes to second mullins
to the plate mount castle to third
we got a ball game at camden yards five
to one with two on and nobody out
and the orioles will bring the tying run
to the plate
and a line driving a right field a base
hit for santander
that will bring in one
everybody else moves up a base
a two-strike curve ball
from stammond and santander made him
pains five to two three on one out
orioles down three in the eighth
breaking ball through the right side
base hitterish
a stop sign for severino after hayes
scores
santander to second the tying runs in
scoring position
who reassigned first a three run eight
finning and counting for the never say
die birds
tying run at second he got the goal
ahead run at first and gutierrez is
going to complete the bat around
be on time for the fastball and he was
in the center field severino scores
sunton near behind him
a five run eighth inning and the orioles
have tied the game
the former royal kelvin gutierrez
does in his old team for the biggest hit
of his orioles career
and here's cedric mullins for the second
time in the eighth inning eighth pitch
sprints to mullins
into the air to right
he got underneath it
hunter dozier circles and dozier drops
the baseball
he dropped the ball
two runs score
oh my goodness
hunter dozier came into this game this
inning as a defensive replacement
and right now he would like to be
defensively replaced
the orioles have taken the lead mullins
at second seven of five o's
here's mount castle
ryan mount castle to drive left field
deep and out of here
ryan mount castle a two-run home run
it's a monsoon in the eighth inning
nine runs for the orioles
it'll be up to dylan tate now to collect
the final three outs with the orioles up
by four
well if rs goes to third
airfield goes to second now the batter
will be andrew ben attendee
the pitch
a swing and a high drive deep to right
that's down the line and gone and the
royals are within one at nine to eight
on andrew ben attendee's 13th home run
this year
that almost made it all the way to the b
o warehouse
ben attendee has driven in five tonight
and it's nine eight in the ninth well
there he is tyler wells and he is in
to try to pick up the save for the
orioles preserve this one run lead
on the ground into the shift ureas to
first base and the orioles win it
how did they do it they stormed the
castle with a nine run eighth and they
hang on for dear life nine to eight